I think over time Stockton just realized
that the only way
we were going to be able to help
Humanity unlock the secrets of the ocean
was to get past the regulations and just
prove that it could be done as safely as
possible what happened on June 18th may
have proved something very different
Stockton Rush CEO of Ocean Gate
Expeditions piloted a submersible named
Titan on a mission to view the wreck of
the Titanic hours later the Titan
imploded killing all five aboard
the U.S Coast Guard has opened its
highest level investigation into the
incident as experts question whether
flaws in The Titan's design led to its
demise the journal sat down with
Guillermo sunline ocean Gate's
co-founder to discuss what he knows
about Rush the Titan and the vision they
had for the company
when I first met Stockton he struck me
as a very intelligent person he also
struck me as a very Savvy engineer
Russians online started Ocean Gate
Expeditions in 2009 after leaving the
company in 2013 sunline remained as a
minority shareholder initially we didn't
think we were going to build our own
Subs we thought we were going to get
somebody else to build our subs the
industry standard just wouldn't allow
for them to build what we felt we needed
and what we thought Humanity needed to
explore the oceans Ocean Gate wanted a
bigger submersible that could fit up to
five people the Titan was in development
in 2018 after sun Lion's departure
three years later The Vessel was
deployed on its first trip to the
Titanic
in a 2022 CBS news report Rush showed
off the Titan and what he described as
its off-the-shelf components I got these
from a camper world we run the whole
thing with this game controller
while experts say nearly all
submersibles that explore the high
pressure environment of the deep ocean
are made with either Titanium or
high-end steel Ocean Gate decided to
incorporate carbon fiber in The Titan's
body raising questions in the diving
community
discussing the hole in a 2021 interview
Rush struck a defiant tone you know I've
broken some rules to make this I think
I've broken them with with logic and
good engineering behind me the carbon
fiber and titanium there's a rule you
don't do that well I did his thoughts
about breaking the rules is really about
thinking outside the box and coming up
with innovative solutions internally we
always called ourselves SpaceX for the
oceans elon's doing the same thing at
SpaceX right
most submersible manufacturers opt for a
third-party verification to ensure the
Integrity of its design and construction
a process Ocean Gate didn't follow
industry insiders warned the company in
2018 that this could risk a potentially
catastrophic failure Ocean Gate didn't
respond to the journal's request for
comment
the U.S Coast Guard said its
investigation could lead to civil or
criminal penalties
it's unclear how long it will take to
uncover what exactly happened to the
Lost Titan